E
BEEN PREVENTED SINCE THEY KNEW
ABOUT THE FIRST CASE AND DID
NOTHING.
THE OFFICIALS PUT KIDS LIVES IN
DANGER TO PROTECT WHAT EXACTLY?
WE DON'T KNOW.
ANY KID IN THOSE SCHOOLS COULD
TELL YOU THAT MEN AND WOMEN ARE
NOT THE SAME.
JUST LIKE THEY COULD TELL YOU
THIS CAT LADY ISN'T A CAT.
>> I'M A CAT.
MEOW, MEOW.
I'M NOT A WOMAN DRESSED AS A
CAT.
I AM A CAT.
HOW MANY OF YOU BELIEVE AND
CONFESS THAT I'M A CAT.
HOW MANY OF YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOUR CHILD OR A CHILD FROM THIS
SCHOOL WOULD BELIEVE THAT I'M
ACTUALLY A CAT?
NO ONE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
TRUTH PREVAILS OVER IMAGINATION.
REALITY EXISTS.
DISCERNMENT IS INNATE AND
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WIRED TO
HAVE.
ONE LOOK AT ME AND YOU KNOW THIS
TO BE TRUE.
I'M A WOMANING POSING AS A CAT.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM, THE CAT LADY
HERSELF AND HOST OF THE PATRIOT
BARBIE PODCAST JOINS ME NOW.
LINDSEY, WHAT WAS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING AT THIS SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT MADE YOU HAVE TO
DRESS UP AS A CAT TO PROVE YOUR
POINT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, JESSE,
I'D LIKE YOU TO NOT MISS A
SPECIES.
I'D BE LIKE TO BE ADDRESSED AS A
CAT.
>> I APOLOGIZE.
>> INCLUSIVITY IS ALL I ASK.
THIS WAS A LOCAL SCHOOL IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE THERE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE SCHOOL BOARD WHOSE
NAME IS PAUL VIXLER.
HE'S A MAN, CLEARLY A MAN.
THE ONLY THING HE DOES TO
IDENTIFY AS A FEMALE IS PUT
LIPSTICK ON.
HE GREW HIS HAIR AND HE WEARS
HIS DECEASED WIFE'S CLOTHING TO
SCHOOL, TO SPORTING EVENTS, TO
SCHOOL EVENTS IN FRONT OF THE
CHILDREN.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, HE DEMANDS ON
BEING IDENTIFIED ONE OF TWO
WAYS, EITHER PAUL A MAN'S NAME
OR MRS. VIXLER.
IT'S CLEAR HE HAS A GENDER
IDENTITY CRISIS.
NOT ONLY DOES HE APPEAR IN FRONT
OF THE CHILDREN AND INSIST HE'S
DEFINED AS A WOMAN BUT SITS ON
THE BOARD AND MAKING DECISIONS
FOR THE CHILDREN.
THE POINT I WAS TRYING TO MAKE
AS A CAT, OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN'T
IDENTIFY AS WHATEVER YOU WANT
AND DEMAND THAT OTHER PEOPLE
IDENTIFY YOU AS WHATEVER YOU
WANT, BUT SOMEONE WITH THIS KIND
OF MENTAL ILLNESS CAN ENJOY THAT
MENTAL ILLNESS ALL THEY WANT IN
THE COMFORT OF THEIR HOME.
WHEN YOU PUT THEM IN CHARGE OF
CHILDREN, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
NEW TYPE OF INDOCTRINATION.
THAT'S TERRIFYING SEEING THESE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF OUR KIDS
EDUCATION.
>> IF HE HAS TO GRIEVE OVER HIS
DEAD WIFE, HE CAN GRIEVE
PRIVATELY.
BUT WEARING HIS DECEASED WIFE'S
DRESS AND PUTTING ON LIPSTICK
AND GROWING YOUR HAIR OUT AND
INSISTING -- WHAT GRADE IS THIS?
>> THIS IS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THESE ARE YOUNG VULNERABLE
MINDS.
THE TEACHERS, THE REST OF THE
SCHOOL BOARD ARE IDENTIFYING HIM
AS MISSES AS HE TALKED IN A
MAN'S VOICE.
SO TO SEE THESE PARENTS TAKE NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE EDUCATION
OF THESE KIDS AND TO TEACH THEM
TRUE RIGHT AND WRONG AND TRUE
BIOLOGY AND TRUE FACTS AND
SCIENCE AND TRUTHS IS JUST SO
ALARMING THAT WE HAVE THIS IN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
>> REAL QUICK.
WHEN YOU DID THIS AT THIS
HEARING, DID PEOPLE UNDERSTAND?
HOW DID THEY REACT?
>> THIS IS A GREAT STORY,
ACTUALLY.
THE NEXT DAY AT THE GYM, I SAW
ONE OF THE MEMBERS OF THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
HE LOOKED AT ME A LITTLE ODD.
I SAID I'M SURE YOU DON'T WANT
TO REMEMBER WHO I AM.
HE SAID "THE CAT."
I THOUGHT HE WOULD PROCEED TO
CHEW ME OUT.
HE SAID THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GETTING UP THERE AND SAYING WHAT
YOU SAID.
THANKS NOR BEING BOLD ENOUGH TO
SPEAK TRUTH.
I'VE BEEN FIGHTING THIS AGENDA,
FIGHTING THIS TEACHER AND THIS
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
THERE'S PEOPLE -- THERE'S PEOPLE
ON OUR SIDE.
ALL I TAKES IS A FEW OF US TO
STAND UP AND SPEAK TRUTH AND
FIND THE PARTNERS IN CRIME IF
YOU WILL.
WE REALLY CAN UNITE TOGETHER AND
FIGHT BACK AND SAVE OUR
CHILDREN.
>> WHAT KIND OF EXERCISES DOES A
CAT DO AT THE GYM?
>> OH, YOU KNOW -- THERE'S GOT
TO BE SOMETHING ZINGY I CAN SAY
HERE.
LOTS